when it came to left-wing content versus
right-wing content do you see a
difference between an individual's post
or
corporations posts like was one side
doing more corporate one side more
people individuals i definitely saw more
uh corporate posts that were leftists
and i saw more just individual people
who were right-wing
uh and then a funny thing is with the
with um how they treat certain words so
with
there was something called the bullying
slang list so if i call someone
if i call ian over here if i say ian ian
you're a trump pumper
bear and and you you report it
i as a moderator can see that you ian
reported that comment so it's called a
name face match
interesting so that gives me more power
now the content monitor can say hey ian
ian himself didn't like that comment
and so but trump humper it stays up no
matter what even if you record it yeah
it stays up so what if i call you a
feminazi or a snowflake
oh snap really really snowflake wow yeah
trump humper is okay
trump is okay nazi's okay snowflake and
feminazi are not okay feminazi is no
good but nazi's great
yeah yeah wow yeah so that gives an
example
um kind of what you're getting into i
hope that answers your question yeah
you know uh that's what i assumed that
corporations are pushing the leftist
narrative yeah and the people who follow
it follow it blindly
and then the individuals are right-wing
there's two there's two ways to look at
it for one
the right is individualist so you've got
more people on the right they want to
take care of themselves mind their own
business
and the left is more collectivist so
they have a hierarchical collective
structure
a corporation telling them what to do
and think and just they go along with it
yeah but in the in that sense too it
it's interesting that's why that meme
exists that
without moderation it would all be
right-wing because the individuals would
all be the ones speaking
and the left would not have any kind of
group at all they wouldn't be doing
anything
in fact they'd probably just become
right-wing seeing nothing but right-wing
memes and ideas and
things like that yeah so one of the
interesting aspects of that then is
it seems like there may it's not just a
left-wing bias it's a pro-corporate bias
like is that yeah i mean we see that
just recently we've seen that with uh
was expensified that sent out that email
oh that's right yes yes yes
so expensive by sending them out to all
their consumers basically saying
literally in head in the subject line
vote for joe biden
or there will be a civil war or there
will be a civil war
and you mentioned this collective force
of the left wing and it's like
it's like the borg like you mentioned on
tuesday the borg from star trek yeah
resistance is futile yep and like and
then they were throwing who is that
armstrong
the ceo of the that one tech company um
under the bus because he wouldn't he
said that we don't want to
i don't want to talk about politics at
work um do you remember his name
armstrong which i think was armstrong
i don't know see his name was armstrong
which company was that for um
i don't remember the name i'll look it
up at the top of my head yeah
but yeah so i mean yeah we see that
resistance is futile i mean
they're pressuring they pressured travis
county to retract all lives matter
and that was in like 2016 that was
before it became this big
right now like you know if you're a
corporate entity you pretty much have to
cave into the the woke left mob yeah
what is expensify do you know i think
they s
it hasn't been with expense reports yeah
he's because
he's like well he did like a qa he's
like
well why does the civil war matter are
you overreacting he's like
well in the civil war i wouldn't be able
to bill out expenses there's not going
to be a lot of expense reports in a
civil war so
he's like he so so the gist of this
story is
he is a tech ceo in san francisco
and he sent out a an email to all of his
customers
saying you must vote for joe biden i saw
some people complaining saying
why is he using my private information
for this
he should not be emailing me these
messages outside of the you know the
realms of what his business does
yeah i don't think he broke any laws
doing it but he probably pissed off a
lot of customers
oh yeah but it's crazy the extent to
which i don't care what my expense
report tracking company thinks
when i hire a plumber am i going to be
like by the way who are you voting for
don't worry about the toilet i know it's
broken but let's talk politics no i say
thanks for coming my toad's broken have
at it let me know if you need anything
yeah but could you imagine if you hired
a plumber and he showed up and said
before i fix your toilet
who'd you vote for i i i didn't vote
you didn't vote you want a civil war no
man i took a dump and the toilet's
clogged
that's what i want i don't know what
you're talking about that's where we're
at
people have gone nuts speaking of that
collective mind i mean
this is similar to what um zach voorhees
the google whistleblower kind of
uncovered i'm sorry i gotta stop real
quick
uh i have to apologize to all plumbers i
think anybody doing a part a hard job
like that probably wouldn't be a leftist
anyway right exactly
doing hard work kind of this is true now
i have to apologize to all the leftist
plumbers
i'm just kidding anyway continue zack
voorhees who's this guy yeah so
zack force is the google whistleblower
so he went public about a year and a
half ago
i remember with uh he worked as a
software engineer for google for eight
and a half years
and he uncovered their algorithms that
are basically just trying to shape
kind of that collective mind in a way
shape humanity it was ml fairness is
that what he understood yeah fairness
yep yeah exactly
uh alabama algorithmic fairness yeah and
it was basically this
essentially a way to influence as well
the 2020 election
and i'm also working with dr robert
epstein oh yeah
and uh he uh he's actually my 501c3
sponsor for my foundation
um and so he uncovered you know the fact
that google was influencing search
results in the 2016 election
towards hillary clinton and this guy's a
classic liberal
someone who's not he's got photos so dr
robert epstein
he's got pictures of him with like the
clintons and he's like give it a thumbs
up he's all happy and excited
and then he was like google is swinging
the election in favor of the clintons
and this is scary not exactly in favor
of hillary
yeah cool and he has signed the science
to back it up i mean behavioral research
so
i want to have him so so are we is this
our last election
if trump loses i and i'm not saying this
to
to praise trump i'm saying if the
democrats win and the machine
is favoring them to win are we just
under the boot of the machine if we
can't stop it now
yeah pretty much i mean uh i hate to be
a pessimist all right i'm going fishing
guys
ian take over the show
how pessimistic are you do you think
this is the end i think there's some
hope i think there's a glimmer of hope
um there's actually a lawsuit coming up
i talked to this guy named jason fick
fyk and he has a lawsuit against
facebook facebook essentially
stole his page deleted his page and
tried to sell it to someone else
whoa what yeah and he had like i don't
know
540 million followers or something like
that huge account
and so his lawsuit might go to the
supreme court it might be appealed to
the supreme court
and clarence thomas clarence thomas just
issued an
opinion last week on malwarebytes versus
something else basically issued a really
important opinion
that's talking about section 230. so
there's a glimmer of hope
and it has to do with how this ninth
circuit has
interpreted section 230 incorrectly so
interesting so when with jason's lawsuit
basically he
um he tried to sue them and then
facebook's like oh well we're not
the publisher but the publisher
is different than a publisher so right
they're like we're not
we're not that publisher and as in we
weren't the ones who originally wrote
the content
but they were acting as a developer
because they were promoting or
de-boosting certain content
right and so that's the argument that of
that jason fick has
is basically to fix section 230 we need
to
have it either reinterpreted by the
basically we need to have it
interpreted correctly by the supreme
court because it's interpreted been
interpreted incorrectly
by the ninth circuit court of california
which has given additional protections
and immunity
under section 230 c1
yeah not c2 because we always talk about
c2 so hold on so
what uh can you explain section 230 just
uh easily for people who don't
know what it is yeah so in 1996 um the
congress created a law
that was supposed to protect children on
the internet from bad content
so that if someone has a
um yeah someone hosts uh like a platform
or a message board
that message board would not be
responsible for every single comment
but it gave immunity to these platf i
hate to reuse the word platform but
it's like it's like digital information
site or something i think it's like the
language
yeah like there's there's service
providers there's uh information content
providers
which is you and me and then there's
another category but yeah
uh for the sake of simplicity yes it
gave platforms immunity
but yes so the way it was designed that
was interpreted as fine but the way it's
been reinterpreted by the ninth circuit
gives additional immunity to these
platforms basically
uh how it started was there was like a
news website i guess and someone
commented on it saying i think it was
the dude from wolf of wall street
actually who got who got who was like
the subject of the suit
someone someone went on a website
commented this dude is like a scammer or
something like that
so he sued the website saying you
published this comment the website said
no we didn't there was a comment from
somebody else
so this led to the creation of this law
that said okay you know
newsnewswebsite.com can't be responsible
for a comment
yeah so we're going to pass this law
that says you are not responsible for
this content
so long as you know you are not
the publisher or editor of the content
then the website said wait wait wait
but we might want to remove content i
mean do we lose this protection if
someone posts a picture of like a dead
cat or something
and they're like okay that's a good
point okay so you're not responsible
for what users post and you can remove
things
if they're objectionable and they said
excellent this was like
god tear immunity the lawmakers didn't
realize what they had just done
now literally everything's objectionable
what does it even mean nobody even knows
so it's a good faith effort to moderate
you know if it's lewd lascivious or
objectional so now you get twitter being
like this guy tweeted learn to code
well that's objectionable nuked and
they're protected
they have they have immunity no other
company has this
yeah so it gets even crazier when we
talk about facebook
because facebook has fact checkers now
that are a special class of people that
they choose
not individuals who just sign up and do
things no it's their choice
their criteria and they can say you're a
liar
they can take something you said and put
a big thing over it says fake news
which is a statement of fact false
information this person is wrong
that is coming from facebook and no one
else so this is what's crazy to me if
you want to make an argument
that you know facebook twitter whoever
shouldn't be sued because a commenter
said something
i'm listening if you tell me that
facebook can appoint people to insult
and make statements about other people
or defame by calling them liars well
facebook's responsible for that
facebook's the one who's authorized that
posting
it is not the same as a a random user
signing up and using it they've said
okay these seven people are allowed to
say whatever they want it's like okay
well facebook
when you put a card over my post you
have editorialized and
you have personally published a
statement so so we
we need 230 reform i know trump has said
repeal 230 which would be a huge mistake
yeah these these platforms wouldn't
exist without it they do need immunity
so long as they're acting
in good faith and they're not just
removing legal speech
so so you you mentioned before you have
some ideas on 2 30. yeah exactly i
that's a good interpretation of it so um
yeah the way that it's been interpreted
that section 230 has been interpreted by
the ninth circuit court of california
uh facebook protection additional
protections under c1
so that whole motive part where being of
being a good samaritan
doesn't even apply so in jason fix case
when facebook
fought back and with their appeal
whatever their their response
they didn't have to argue on the basis
of section
um c2 they just argued on the
merits of c1 which the knights circuit
had interpreted that favor
which favors them and so no i agree with
you on that i
i think that repealing it completely
would be a disaster
now i've heard that edge of pi actually
has
authority to to reinterpret and reform
second two and he should have done it a
long time ago
so forgive me if i have no faith in him
or any one of these republicans to get
it done
yeah can can you define section one
and section two of two three three c one
and c one c two
so i don't have the i i have the the
what uh jason fick wrote about it um oh
wait wait we actually have it yeah
you have second one yeah i got it right
in front of us so section c2 is the one
that we're all familiar with that talks
about
so um right so uh c1 says treatment of
publisher or speaker no provider or user
of an interactive computer service shall
be treated as the publisher or speaker
of any information provided by another
information content provider which is
like the individual
two is civil liability no provider or
user of an interactive computer service
shall be held liable on account of a
any action voluntarily taken in good
faith to restrict access to
or availability of material the provider
or user considers to be obscene lewd
lascivious filthy excessively violent
harassing
or otherwise objectionable whether or
not material is constitutionally
protected or b
any action taken to enable or make
available to information content
providers
or others the technical means to
restrict access to material described in
paragraph
one so basically the first a c one is
you can't i'm not liable for what
another person said
c2 is we're allowed to remove whatever
we want
as long as we're doing it in good faith
which basically this point means
literally whatever
and you could argue that if they're
putting like a notice out that says
tim poole posted fake news that they're
become a publisher under section one
c1 uh so what i'm saying is
uh well let me tell you the story
somebody i i posted something about
bill clinton and epstein island
everything i said was factually correct
i said bill clinton was seen in these
flight logs he was
uh he was seen on the plane he was id'd
by a witness on the island and this is
not major breaking news
something like that i'm i'm paraphrasing
right now because i don't have the tweet
in front of me
but somebody screenshotted it because it
went viral
post it to facebook and facebook put a
card over it saying fake
false information or something yeah that
was facebook doing that
facebook put a flag saying false
information on my post
they made a statement about me that i
had lied to the public
so they refused to take it down they
become a publisher at that point
under c1 they are the speaker yeah it
sounds seems like that i think that's a
good argument yep
and if you look at the definition of
development which is actually in the law
it says you know choosing to promote
prioritize well this is not the law but
basically choosing to promote prioritize
advance boost or increase the
availability or usability of information
is by definition development go look up
development and web services so i'm
reading from jason fix analysis
but yeah i mean the service provider
yeah they're they're sponsoring ads so
the entire nature of their business
violates section 230 yeah because what
do they do all day they
boost ads they replace other people's
content in front of other people's
content
um oh wow so that negates it yeah that
negates the
community that makes sense because one
of the arguments that we've all been
saying about twitter and facebook for a
long time is
if they choose the winners and losers
they may as well be the new york times
the only difference the new york times
is i hire you right for me and then they
choose which to go up on the site
whereas twitter is everybody write for
free and then we'll choose which ones go
up on the site
yeah and even clarence thomas in his
opinion uh and that was
malwarebytes versus enigma's enigma
software and that was this past tuesday
october 13th
wow so recently yeah very recent wow and
uh so
he said the ninth circuit court
incorrectly held the subsection 230 c1
does not render
subsection 230 c2a redundant
as subsection 230 c2 provides an
additional shield from liability so
there was some redundancy so that's why
it needs to be reinterpreted either by
agitpi
but i agree with you or the supreme
court but i agree with you because you
know we had that anti-trust hearing
a couple months ago where we had the
tech ceos to testify i guess there's
another subpoena
but you know jim sensenbrenner this
congressman from wisconsin he's been in
like 21 terms
and he's out there saying well we
shouldn't punish successful companies
like because these he's a republican
right he's republican go figure but
the rhinos and the dinos have been
sitting in there milking the milk in the
system suckling the tea to big business
yeah
and that's why i don't vote and that's
why i'm voting now because i think
something's happening
you've got on the left and the right
populists and i think the left hates the
right the right
well i shouldn't say hey but they they
think both sides think each other as
crazy
yeah but i'll tell you what i would
rather i i want to see these
these people who sat in office for
decades
doing nothing saying the bare minimum
taking cash from big corporations and
then just being oh whatever i'm not
gonna do anything for you
who cares if the people are suffering he
got a job huh
congratulations but i hope it was worth
it but yeah just to summarize section
230 i mean imagine like
your public library and you go to the
public library and you know the library
itself is not responsible for what's in
the content of those books right
but whereas if you go to barnes noble
like they're promoting certain books
there's certain books that are on
special so that's kind of the difference
and
and so facebook's kind of morphed from a
public library into
this uh barnes and noble so to speak
yeah we have a it mines
if it's not legal in the united states
then it's taken down and it's actually
state by state and it's a connecticut
thing because that's where the
corporation is based so it's not legal
in connecticut
it's taken off the site but if it's
legal it stays on the site it just goes
into different buckets depending on if
it's objectionable and then you have to
opt in
to see objectionable content by default
everyone kind of has the
rated g filter on that's interesting
because jack dorsey has talked about
that
like uh some kind of system where
instead of getting banned i think it was
jack maybe i'm maybe i'm thinking of
somebody else
but there was one i think it was jack
dorsey if that if if if
instead of getting banned you get put in
basically like the underbelly
and people can choose to go into the
dark crevice of
horror twitter and see all of the nasty
pictures and photos
and people and it's still like up to
discretion
what's nasty and that's a little weird
because you put it in the terms and like
objectionable is a horrible word to use
because like how do you define that
it's up to the the admin basically yeah
but how
i don't know we kind of have our peers
can judge now we've got like a 12-person
jury system where if they judge that
it's objectionable then
it goes the adjustable thing and you can
appeal that objectionable
you know that's a great idea yeah so
actually this really
actually relates to something i was
researching um so
back in the sixth well it started in the
20s but in england
there was this thing called the british
board of film censors
so it's basically that like hey there's
this consensus opinion
what's culturally appropriate obviously
things that we see on tv
would be you know obscene to someone
from 100 years ago like living in the
1920s
so what's acceptable publicly publicly
to be viewed
and so this british board of film
censors there's this documentary called
video nasties you can search it on
youtube and it talks about how the
british board of film censorship
basically
you know could make it their own rules
so this famous quote from john
trevillian he said we have no rules
which i think is important
i think it's the only way to do it you
see if you have your rules you either
got to stick to them
or you have to interpret them and i
think either is foolish
so he's basically admitting like hey we
wow we're in charge of the film
censorship we determine
whether the movies get approved or not
get a well they don't get approved
and we have no rules and it really made
me think of facebook because
sure they have the rules but they don't
follow them half the time they make
exceptions whenever they want to protect
someone
that they want to protect thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you